okay why don't we get started
so good morning everyone I'm Alex Grady
co-director of the bb2k hundred
Coordination Center so today we're
continuing our computing overview with
our third talk and destruction I have
the pleasure of introducing dr. Terry
auditor from UC San Diego he is a
professor of genetics and bioengineering
the department of medicine and it's
director of the well known national
resource for network biology and the pan
Diego center persistent biology he is a
fellow the American Association for the
Advancement of science as well as of the
American Institute for medical and
biological engineering
some of you may already actually be
familiar with dr. ackard work he is the
founder of sight escape and open source
products medics proper platform that
some of you may have been yes before
visualizing the like literature option
networks so today dr. Arthur is going to
share some of his experiences and
insights into the practical challenges
of running a research lab at the
intersections of data science and
biomedicine something that several you
will likely face in the future
so dr. Isaac and thank you for joining
us today
and the floor is yours okay very good
thanks very much for that introduction
what I'm going to talk about today is
really four points that I consider to be
key considerations when you build a data
science and laboratories I'll talk a bit
about my own work through through
vignette illustrate these before points
these aren't the only four points that
one might want to consider is and one
builds out their own data sciences
laboratory or or improves an existing
data sciences laboratories but they're
certainly four of the more important
points in my experience the first thing
I'll talk about is lavishes and and this
is first because it underlies and
underscores everything that that you do
in the lab why you get up in the morning
is this technology biology medicine or
something else and clearly articulating
the vision as specifically as possible
but but with as much a vision as
possible often
my time in the next hour or or slightly
less talking about getting data it turns
out the more you think about places and
sources of data whether they be external
or internal to the lab through
collaboration or one-on-one it's a very
key issue in the life of a data
scientist so most of my talk actually
ends up really focusing on on sources of
data near the end I'd like to touch on
computing infrastructure so of course
one needs to think as a data scientist
about what is the hardware that that one
needs to have and one's environment and
then finally I will say a few words
about tool to build process process ends
up being more important than one might
might first realize in terms of one's
research flowing into development and
ultimately tool insemination so that
will come at the very end of the talk
so without further ado let me let me
take the first issue on last lab mission
and the way I think about this is really
why wise one is the data scientist what
we want to go to work in the morning and
what keeps you getting up in the morning
and going to work every day of course
all of us have our reasons but there
really are three important reasons that
I can think of in terms of driving your
research one is biological discovery so
is the most important thing in your life
questions or statements such as I want
to reveal how biology or where light is
structured functions involved now and
today the scientist let me make it clear
that you were going to be using the
toolbox
among other tools of data science and
chemists would ask this question a
geneticist been asked this question and
they would be using a different tool box
and of course one's free to use multiple
tools from those different boxes but but
the point is it's very possible to be a
data scientist yet your first allegiance
is to biological discoveries which might
mean you you you largely use
state-of-the-art tools that already
exist to answer those questions
the next question would be medicine so
independent of how life actually works I
want to help people get better I want if
your cancer would be if I had to save my
last goal from the medical point of view
but again you want to cure cancer using
a data scientist toolbox and
increasingly I think we're seeing that
that the ability to cure diseases and to
enter push forward biomedical research
into those diseases is dependent on data
science and finally is a listed here is
probably what's the most common answer
this question among data science
individuals or labs which is what gets
you up in the morning is the urge to
develop new technology or methodology so
you you have that n s is commonly and
unfortunately in a derogatory way sort
of referred to as a hammer in search of
a nail but of course
cameras can can can can easily find the
correct nail loss at the time but the
point is you've used bills the hammer
you have a data science analysis you
have an algorithm a software or Hardware
device etc that you believe is going to
revolutionize largely the previous two
disciplines either biological discovery
and or or medicine so now like I'll do
throughout this talk I'll try to make
some general points and it's been
diffuse lies illustrating how I've
answered those questions in my own life
and lab so I am driven to get up in the
morning because I have the as you'll see
not an ambitious goal I'd like to build
a complete model of cell structure and
function but we automate that process
much like one canal build a full model
of a genome through automated or at
least semi automated genome sequencing
pipeline and so just to give you a
couple of motivations and arguments for
why I think that is an important
motivation in my life I'm driven by this
idea lately that networks like people
are generating on the left here of
either physical
in protein interaction or gene
expression or so-called genetic
interactions lots of ways that
scientists are linking together
molecules like genes and proteins and
themselves
the problem is with with this common
view is that is that cells don't look
like that cells look much more like the
picture we see on on the right and it
turns out that both the picture on the
right and the left are the same object
or representations of the same object
and in cells this is a proteome the
proteasome as you may know it's a
vacuum-cleaner of the cell and we're
looking at the proteasome on its side so
here is the core in the middle that eats
the proteins and here is the regulatory
particle on either side and you can see
of course through several folds of
symmetry there it's very hard to see
that structure on the left although if
one starts the period when it sees a
higher density of interaction among the
core proteins which we were the same
colors in red and yellow and one sees a
higher density of protein and other
interactions on the right side among the
regulatory subunits but the question
that really we've been addressing now
towards towards a ultimately model of
the structure and function of cell which
starts to look much more like the
picture on the right is as follows so so
we're trying to come up with algorithms
and tools from data sciences point of
view it will take all of these Network
data that I just showed you here and
here is a and first compute a master
gene in similarity network based on all
of those raw interaction data but don't
stop there
from a gene and similarity Network ask
the question how how far can we push
that towards what starts to look like
models of the cell and as far as we've
gotten so far we haven't I should admit
gone all the way towards structure
that's a very very hard problem but we
have been able to push this towards
hierarchical models of the components of
cells so you saw in the ferns OMA case
there were already several orders of
hierarchy the proteasome contained or an
emancipatory particle
each of those contains
each of those subunits can take proteins
so we've at least gotten as far as being
able to flesh out that type of structure
largely directly from these kinds of
interaction data that hierarchy begins
to look a lot like what we've already
heard about in this series and ontology
so we directly align those oncology's
with the gene ontology to see what is
the similarity with what's been curated
from the literature of course this
hierarchy I'm talking about an hour's
entire image is driven so just quickly
the ways the way that works is you it's
a clustering algorithm with a couple of
key twists rather than build a binary
tree
like most clustering algorithms or many
custom algorithms do you want to build
what's called a directed acyclic graph
which is not coincidental II the
structure of a gene ontology or other
ontology which means that internal
clusters first of all can have more than
two children so here is an internal
cluster that has three children why is
that a good idea because if you have a
protein complex it can certainly have
more than two subunits you can have
arbitrary numbers and you also want to
allow for pleiotropy the idea that an
internal cluster can participate in two
or more parent clusters so it's a
variant of clustering with with that
twist and afterwards you align it to a
literature curated ontology and then
just to give you an example of how this
works this process was just recently
applied by my very capable recipe Mike
Kramer to autopsy and so here is
generated or I should say analyzed and
we'll get to this in a second in the
public domain a bunch of network data
like protein protein interactions
co-expression
and other types of networks among the
autopsy ggmoffatt regimes as if we start
with a CG proctology
now you'll suspend your disbelief here
because we're not showing you the raw
data but the RNA process these with
overall similarity of four between pairs
of genes so you can see in the
interaction data jeans like ATG 27 in 10
or more similar genes like 10 12 and 7
or
similar I look at you 10 participation
both of those clusters so already you
need a clustering algorithm that can
that can correctly create both clusters
for one component and oh look there's a
much larger cluster here which
encompasses all of these genes ATG 10
all the way to 80 to 8 so in the
hierarchy at right you can start to see
that structure and what we hope is a
much more clear and interpretive way
than looking at either the raw interact
omics data or these heat maps so you can
see here that a cg 10 is placed in the
two higher-order components defined
exactly binding data and now we have a
larger component here which contains all
of these APG genes the names that you
see on at least these blue terms come
from alignment to the gene ontology in
the case of these red internal
subsystems or terms those were not in
the gene ontology but it turns out have
literature of supporting them and so we
were able to name those four since terms
and submit those names to the gene
ontology and those are now in in that
resource and then finally we see a
number here like 183 this is a truly
orphaned component we have evidence that
if the true component based on the data
yes there is no evidence and go for that
particular grouping and there's no
evidence in current literature for that
particular group in beyond oh you can of
course zoom out and look not just an
autopsy but the entire cells worth of
genes and so this tree here starts with
all James underneath the root again
through alignment to go this is labeled
the cellular component branch ago
because that's what we aligned against
and then you see quickly a new partition
into a mitochondrial part and membrane
park and intracellular part especially
in the intracellular part and can name
because go names lots of these internal
structures but this lot is up with our
names and those are exactly the new
biological discoveries so to get back to
the example of the chromosome here is so
one right here is the old picture that
you would do in a network browser but
now if you look at it
from the hierarchical or ontological
point of view here again based on the
exact same data you start to see the
structure of the proteasome at least in
terms of the hierarchy where you have a
cronyism complex which splits the core
and the regulatory particle which split
into subunits and proteins and so forth
so that's that's an example that I'll
carry forward throughout this talk but
let's let's get back to how that relates
to the lab mission so that definitely is
a new technology rather than a
biological discovery or a medical
discovery however of course once you are
driven by one of these goals which I'm
clearly driven by the third one here
then you have ample opportunities if you
play your cards correctly to to imagine
it which house those houses with within
bearable and biological discovering
medicine and we'll see examples of that
in a little bit but first let me now
talk about the second end and and what
ends up being the majority of this talk
which is the very exciting and sometimes
thorny issue of where you get data as a
data scientist like any talk is one can
try to classify it into into different
parts so here what I've done is written
is trying to spread out different ways
of getting data from or across the
continuum where you have easy entry but
let's novelty in control all the way
where you have a higher bar of entry but
complete control and hopefully work more
novelty although this of course is is a
broad generalization and there's lots of
novelty certainly to be found all
throughout the spectrum so the easiest
bar to entry as a starting data
scientist is of course public datasets
it's surprising the number of data
science labs that have a perfectly good
career with only looking at public 18
cents without doing any of these other
form activities that I'm about to talk
to now if one does not love to
operating in vacuum and increasingly in
our connected society we're encouraged
and and and have ample opportunity to
work together one can think about
accessing data through different kinds
of collaboration there's really many
ways to think about this but I think
about it in terms of two types many to
many collaborations which are sometimes
called from 40th and one-on-one more
focused collaborations between you and
and a co-worker who could be either a
true same institution or or at a
different institution and then finally
pushing down this pipeline or this is
continuum the last category would be to
bring those experiments into your own
lab and the way to do that is if if you
yourself do not feel get qualified if
you have not been trained by a chemistry
or genetics or some of some other
molecular biological laboratory
discipline then I've seen lots of cases
where that nonetheless is able to run
and very simple to start and then we run
a very successful experimental program
and the way to do it with the host lab
so this requires a lot of trust with the
host partner here but if you have say a
neighbor who with whom you have a very
good working relationship then you can
often come up with an agreement where
you'll pay for experiments within their
lab or you've already hired a postdoc or
a technician into your lab and they'll
measure that that person within their
own their own lab at least some of the
time the final position on this on this
continuum is going further and to take
on all that experimental laboratory
activity yourself
and again there's there's a lot of
laboratories including my own that took
this plunge at the beginning of their
careers and and I certainly wouldn't go
back at this point and I'll talk talk a
bit about that but but if all of these
loads I'd like to say are our successful
ways of running a data Sciences lab you
just have to choose which kind of lab
you want to be so in terms of public
data because a lot of what I focus on is
building models of cells with ultimate
application to understanding and curing
cancer and again every time I say that I
have to smile and I'm sure some of you
are as well it's a lofty goal here so
but but but the point is when it is you
want to keep getting out of bed for 30
years or maybe your entire career you
don't want to just have a goal it's
going to get you out of bed this week so
in the case of cancer there is in many
ways cancer is a flagship of widely
available public data and the the jewel
in the eye of that flagship is is the
Cancer Genome Atlas or TCGA where at
this point in time there's in excess far
in excess of 10,000 exomes I should say
here the both the genomes for progenitor
available this just shows one such
genome it was an early Geno generated by
the Cancer Genome Atlas this is a
so-called circus plot here we're up were
a single patient who had been sequenced
and also subjected to a variety of other
loads of data collection and analysis
but here they're really focusing on the
genome so you can see here around the
circle you have the 22 chromosomes plus
the X and the y and then in successively
smaller and smaller tracks around this
circle you can see different types of
analysis they've performed to extracted
four kinds of information about the raw
genomic sequence so in terms of single
nucleotide substitutions you're looking
at that here in this yellow tracks is
counting the number you see as you walk
along the chromosome from one to the
other you can then get into to the
different kinds of substitutions you you
see there and other kinds of changes you
can then get into copy number variants
or long segments of DNA that are
amplified or to read it so here you can
look at amplification deletions and so
on and so then if you take a step back
and look at the collection of all data
that
that's available through a resource like
the Cancer Genome Atlas they've really
made it very very accessible so a few
clicks away if you simply google TCGA
cancer and you can get to specific
issues where all of the patient data
that have been collected for that
specific cancer tissue can be can be
accessed so if one is interested in had
a net clima cell carcinoma here is the
data page that that you find so there's
a total of 528 cases currently in in the
TCGA of which just shy of 500 have been
sequenced at least from the exome but
then I mentioned they've collected a
whole variety of layers of molecular end
and finally clinical information which
are mostly survival occasionally you get
drug response information in the
clinical column here but it's a lot of
data and and at least the first couple
of tiers of those data are pre easily
accessible if one was increasingly raw
data one has to to obtain the proper
access but hundreds if not thousands of
last have taken access including my own
so it's if it's not complicated to do
now my lab data network lab we also are
very interested in public domain data
set describing molecular networks of
which just like cancer genomes
there are medics here I just missed a
demo category without mentioning the
individual database and I'll talk about
that maybe a little bit later but you
have metabolic networks that are
essentially a tend to be the old barrier
mannheim wall chart people used to have
in the lab on the lab wall
transcriptional networks which have been
measured increasingly systematically
with techniques like chip seek genetic
and protein interaction networks protein
interaction networks are being measured
with technologies like
affinity purification tandem mass
spectrometry where they yeast two-hybrid
system and a variety of other related
experimental technologies and again many
labs are generating these data since
positive
I'm assuming if all our sales one can
always take the prolific mRNA and
protein expression data that are out
there in databases like the gene
expression omnibus or gia and and from
those profiles of mRNA levels for each
gene compute changing similarities which
which can be interpreted and used as as
networks we started putting it in my own
lab a lot of these data but been work
more specifically not just the rider
action data but some of the sub networks
and the cell models derived from those
data into into the database called the
network data exchange or index this now
contains other here we show just a
variety of sources of networks this then
contains we certainly have a focus of
cancer networks like mutinied pathways
interaction database where the host up
here because we were funded by the NCI
and our interest is cancer but there's a
variety of diseases through attack what
is related to those here in the database
now when you have this various kinds of
data in the public domain
I just want to give you another vignette
of ways that our lab and a purely public
domain data-driven way I've had been
able to put together these different
data sets for for productive line of
research and so what we thought we could
do is use these protein networks as a
scaffold of potential pathways in which
or on which to integrate heterogeneous
Tetrazzini
patient cancer mutation profiles and
heterogeneous patient mRNA expression
level today I'll focus mainly on the
patient cancer mutation profiles with
the idea here can you use the networks
to group patients that may have
different genes mutated in their tumors
but nonetheless are mutating the same
networks and pathways as a way of taking
what has been called in one patient
those can't be grouped with any others
for for diagnosis or therapy
and getting extra power and insight for
proving them exit pathway level the
algorithm we used here to do this
integration is a algorithm that's been
very powerful and network science as a
whole it's called network propagation it
also goes by the name of network
smoothing or sometimes diffusion
sometimes random walk models are
envelope all of these names are
essentially synonymous for the same
underlying method and I won't go into
the mathematics here but simply take you
through a high-level intuition of how
this approach works I just say these I'm
citing two papers here one is my word ed
sheeran Labs from Tel Aviv the new-new
and Al and IO and the other is from Ben
Raphael's lab who used this technique to
develop a very successful approach
called pocket and and it will talk about
in the next life the water activities
but the idea here network propagation is
this if you have a patient mutation data
set I'm calling that patient genotype
run and yellow or patients in a situ in
Google the data set will indicate some
mutations in genes for that patient so
here are the yellow mutations in the
yellow patients and the blue mutations
in the blue patients these data are
extremely heterogeneous motivating the
need for this approach but occasion when
you do find patients will mutate the
same commonly mutated cancer gene maybe
this green gene here the stadium in
those patients is a very common player
in cancer like p53 but the question is
can you find more common knowledge than
that at the network level and so the
wave propagation works is it pretends
that instrumentation is the source of
heat and that the protein interactions
and other molecular interactions you
have in this network can conduct that
heat through their network neighbors and
their neighbors neighbors and so on to
to convergence and and convergence
depends on on one parameter it depends
on how much especially the ratio of heat
you inject to the amount of T at every
unit time being diffused into the
atmosphere so
big Nike evaporated refusing upwards
from this network into the atmosphere
and so ascetics a you get some spreading
from the you sources with those being
the hottest the neighbors being the
hottest and then and then D temperature
falling off around that depending on the
settings parameter and so having to fuse
those two datasets you now see that
there's a large green region over here
which represents hot protein in both
patients that is to say what we've done
is we've restored a patient profile from
a few ones and aciem zeros for the genes
that are mutated to a quantitative for
forever inching indicating not whether
if it mutated in the patient but it's
network proximity to mutations so if you
have an upstream factor it yields the
heat if you have a downstream factor if
you'll see heat inside a signaling
pathway if you have a member of the same
protein complex than it feels that he as
the other member that was mutated and
that's how you can begin to get you
striking out similarities between
pictures again then Raphael is using a
hot net algorithm it's been very
successful at finding cancer pathways
using this approach and in our in our
hands we pivoted the question and trying
to stratify patients using this approach
and so here is a network that stratified
and identify is a particularly
aggressive subtype of what a variant
cancer the idea here is that while part
of any two patients in the subtype
mutates of changing all of the patients
in the subtypes mutated gene somewhere
on this slide in this in the sub Network
and that's how the network knowledge
helps here I'm showing you evidence that
these subtypes are significantly
clinically or some government with
respect to survival this blue sometimes
is that aggressive network I just showed
you so for mutated in that then you are
in the blue subtype with poor survival
that for survival replicates in future
cohorts that have come out after our
initial study this is
a second large public repository of
cancer data by the way the international
cancer genomics consortium this is an
Australian cohort of ovarian of women
with ovarian cancer and here we're
essentially not reformulating the site
gnostic we're just using it to show that
if you mutate that same network
you also get poor survival comes okay so
that's that's one vignette for my group
where where it's ruling for actually is
nothing to Vindhyas i should say we're
really we're focused entirely on on
public datasets as you can already TCGA
was actually the result of a large
collaboration although what's
interesting is my group is not where at
least was not at the beginning part of
TCGA we became involved near the end
only after success with with this method
on the public a today they made
available um if you're interested in
joining a consortium from the get-go
with respect to cancer even there are
here I've made a shortlist of four
different consortium that that either
are just completing or just getting
started so the Cancer Genome Atlas
itself has officially ended but that is
already given rise to what's been called
the pan-cancer analysis of whole genome
and that's well underway transitioning
from actual analysis to can't answer or
full genome analysis some of the same
answer of tumors there is other
satellite projects such as the free
Cancer Genome Atlas the cancer immunity
Atlas I'll talk in just a slide about
the cancer cell map initiative that that
I've been involved in formation of
there's a cancer cell Alice which seeks
to define all cell types to as a single
cell RNA sequencing level and cancer
this project is just getting underway
and also a consortium and so on and so
forth so Explorer for insensible imaging
and advanced image recognition
capability in building databases of
tumor cell images so again this is just
cancer incidence there's a short list in
any disease focus area now of large
consortium to become involved in if if
you so choose and depending on the stage
of your career I think it's either
advisable or an advisable I think the
the clear Pro of a consortium life like
one of these is that there's enormous
energy in the critical mass of folks and
also fundings that can be had in the
critical mass of folks that come
together around the common cause the the
con is that one can become lost and all
of that and so you know if I had any
advice to someone starting their data
Sciences laboratory it would be
certainly be involved and and don't make
it the only thing that you do I think in
this day and age is still worth having
your independent research laboratory
activity and and pursuing these
consortiums when he's consortium as a
secondary activity but but the the pros
are are really quite strong I must admit
and so here's here's just the one we've
recently formed around networks with the
goal to to having a sequence many many
different cancer genomes can we now
understand hi in order protein network
structures to help us explain some of
those those mutations and marshalling
people together to try to to
systematically define those protein
protein and genetic interaction and
transcriptional interaction networks so
now let me talk about what a1
collaboration one of the nice things
about having started with public data
and showing proof of concept of a
particular approach with a tool that
might have come out of your lab is now
people might get interested and and of
course they can get interested by
reading your papers they can also get
interested by you reaching out to them
depending on on whether they're at your
same institution or they're in a
different institution that either easier
or harder but certainly conferences are
a great place to form as connections
even across institutions
this is a collaboration that I became
involved with after that that network
stratification page will be published in
2013 one of my colleagues here at UC San
Diego is Joe Gleeson he was not studying
cancer he studies rare childhood
diseases and in this particular case he
was studying a disease called hereditary
[ __ ] paraplegia or HSP Joe tells me
that HSP is what they call a complex
Mendelian disorder which means that in
any one family or child is one gene
typically the causes that disease but
from pedigree pedigree of unrelated
families then it's typically gentle but
it's different means
that's the complexity so here we were
able to work together using essentially
not not the exact same but but what's
essentially a very similar approach to
the one I just described eccentric
propagation here to to find a number of
disease genes or the patient's P disease
based on their proximity through
networks to known disease genes and so
what you're seeing here are the seed or
known proteins from before the study and
red are the candidate genes where we had
power for some of these genes to find
them only because of the network
proximity that you see here if you just
look at the marginal Association of
mutations or variants in these genes
with the phenotype without Network
knowledge admitting genes together you
would not empower to define those those
genes so as an example of a plan between
collaboration and and one's own work the
public data set activity but but now let
me talk about the the last two
categories here which are transitioning
to give you kinds of experiments going
in your in your left and for the for
this point I want to invoke my zero sir
Oren Fisher who has two very relevant
quotes I don't actually know if RA
Fisher had experiments going in his lab
how
I think he did a lot of collaboration
but he had a very famous quote and the
not so well-known quote that's relevant
the first point is that if you if you
hold your fairness close new controlled
experimental design and validation the
and so the famous float is to consult a
statistician after experiments is
finished is often merely to ask them to
conduct a post-mortem examination you
can perhaps they went experiment died up
and because therein lies a problem that
I think data scientists experience all
the times this one-on-one collaborator
comes to you and it's essentially all
the work in lab has been done and you
can immediately see five things you
would have suggested they change about
about the experiment and of course if if
you have started at the beginning of the
project you might have learned the
course as much as they would have about
the particular biological problem at
hand causing you to change your analysis
or your your plans for analysis so the
closer you you can be involved at the
start of an experiment the better for
all of us conserved there's of course
many ways of doing that but one of them
is is by brain working closely with with
experimentalist either in a host lab or
a neuron lab um the the other point I
want to make here is ends up being
actually a microwave even more important
and it was not something that I saw
immediately but saw over over the first
three or four years that I became
involved in experiment alongside data
science and that's that as you begin to
get your own hand wet or dirty or
whatever the right analogy is here it's
this miraculous thing happens and you
you become in touch with bile if you
like no other method you can certainly
become very educated about biological
systems as an armchair reader of those
processes using textbooks the literature
or hearing about them but somehow when
you reckon bench you gain a completely
different level at least in my own life
formative um and and the real power that
you then have is is the ability to see
these key biological computational
couple problems that it's harder to see
if you're on just one kind of excellence
or or the other and it turns out Fisher
has an excellent quote on on this as
well
sanity and realism can be restored to
the teaching at mathematical statistics
most directly by entrusting it to men
and women who have my personal
experience of research in the Natural
Sciences and so here of course you may
be talking about different ways of
getting that experience but certainly a
laboratory is a wonderful way of really
getting experience beyond data Sciences
which keeps referring to as mathematical
statistics here really get involved in
in the end of biological discipline
itself considering this quote is is
circa 1930 it's even more impressive and
and then really the the the third
practical issue here is once you have
data in your own hands it's you're much
more assured that you're not duplicating
the efforts of someone else of course
it's certainly always feasible that that
someone else has on the exact same
experiment as you are certainly
molecular biologists geneticists and
biochemist also get scooped but it's
it's a higher bar to be to be scooped
certainly and so if you look at my lab
we have the pictures you might expect
like this is Eric and Kay in my group
look who recited taste team developers
looking at a networking tightest day but
then you have moving from the office to
to the lab here we're generating Brian
and lab generating network data and on
analyzing some of the network data for
instance and and so that's been quite a
fun and and frustrating and progressive
exercise and to show how it has been
used in our research plan or program
here let me go back to this example of
constructed hierarchical models
so I already introduced this idea that
we are trying to integrate Network data
of various times together to build open
the ladies hierarchies or data driven
gene ontology of a particular biological
process and ultimately the whole cell as
a hypo folds a lot now once one has some
control over one's experiments one can
now shift for a mode in which one is is
analyzing purely public interact omics
data that's a DMC 2 now asking what new
data set could I generate this we move
to prove this hierarchical model that is
to say the fidelity with which this
hierarchical model represents real
biology actual biological system and to
look at that we of course don't know
biological truth but we do have the very
good gene ontology ontology resource
that's been created from the literature
over a long period of time
so if we use go as at least a broad
standard here is not a it's not a pure
gold standard it's not perfect but but
if we treat go is some sort of broad
standard and we asked how well we
recapitulate go in our data-driven
hierarchical model that's what's been
shown here on the y-axis just as a
fraction of our maximal ability what I
should add here is is out of the box
this approach gives about 60 percent
recovery of cellular component terms and
their interrelationships that are in the
gene ontology at least for defining
these sacrifice and service VA for human
is a little bit lower than that so you
should be thinking perfect for us or the
best performance we can do is about 60
percent recovery ago and that normalized
here to run and now what I'm going to do
is remove studies one by one from the
public domain and a various kinds
genetic interactions protein-protein
interactions and co-expression
interactions and after I remove a
particular PubMed ID again that's what
literally these are PubMed I see I'm
going to reevaluate my ability having
remove
that study and recovering go in my
hierarchy is what you can see here for
at least three times of data is that if
I remove genetic interactions or protein
protein interactions then I do start to
hurt my ability to to recapitulate go
where as interestingly if I remove
clothes freshen settings all the way up
into all fifty but in East Coast freshen
studies that were in the database we we
access given it and still have all of
the other data around in the model you
don't hurt your performance and so this
this allowed us to choose in this case
genetic interactions as the strongest
negative slope pewter that is to say the
interactions which it means the present
time of trees be the most important for
driving this is model and so now because
we had a research lab that over a few
years I fear towards the direct
interaction mapping and I should say our
lab is certainly not the throughput of
the highest group interaction math and
labs out there there are many labs to
pack our capacity of our
jack-of-all-trades lab if you like but
nonetheless we have some abilities to
generate interaction map so here we took
fifty this is back to the autopsy model
we took 50 autopsy jeans and pair them
with about three thousand these teams to
look for genetic interactions in a
matrix like forecast
so all pairs of 55,000 are tested and we
test for interaction across three
conditions and and then you can also
look differentially between an
interaction changes between those those
three autopsy relevant conditions and
what they find is here's an odd way of
animal can't see the similarity with go
I apologize me we change here's a metric
but nonetheless here is how well and you
do recover and go with all prior data
and the public domain if you look at
just this green alone given you target
in one particular process in your lab
with the right genes s and the right
conditions it turns out that even not
considering prior data you can do better
then then all of those public domain
data and again it's just because you've
tailored the data in terms of conditions
of gene
of course if you add those the new data
and the private data together the
recovery of the NGO hierarchy gets even
better and over here who controls
showing that if you if you randomized
things then you you you a relative
performance is expected so that that's
just the latest in yet really of how you
put together a public data set analysis
leading to a collaboration with an
autopsy lab within let us generate our
own network data and come full circle or
that systems biology cycle as shown now
I don't want to build this for everyone
here and I should say there's many
frustrations with with with getting them
all to be present experiments yourself
as a data scientist it is a massive
investment of your time that could
otherwise be going to data science
research directly compounding this fact
is that debugging lab work is much
slower than debugging other kinds of
computation and I think several of us
have appreciated that over over the
years
you can press enter and test whether the
program works in a split second
typically but pressing pressing enter in
lab can take days before you get a
result so - it cost more you have to not
only maintain your your space and and
personnel for the sciences part of your
lab data Amica analysis site if you have
you have to come up with those resources
of course for or experimental science
the lab and that that is a challenge you
have to stand your focus which means
that you're distracted you you you have
more to worry about and that may make
you a less successful science within a
particular task this is what people call
the jack-of-all-trades and and and
another way of saying is is or another
implication of this is that specialized
biologists collaborators will not always
be better than you but but have an
distinct advantage over you you you will
never be a
as high as as they are a knowledge of a
particular biological process or the
particular toolbox of experiments that
women to interrogate that process and
grass roots low threat rating them all
while you spend the time diversifying
your computer science background to
learn experimental biology you're going
to find that your colleagues who are
staying strictly in computer science
domains are going to now over time the
better of you at computer science and
and that's also frustrating but you can
collaborate both ways I find at this
point in my career even though I started
with the degree in computer science and
ended with the PhD in molecular biology
I now in a position where I collaborate
freely with both sides of that things
and I got it okay so that was the bulk
of what I wanted to talk about today I
mission to getting data with my far the
most weighty object in my mind but let
me just say in the net in the last five
minutes or so keywords about both
computing infrastructure end in process
so I think about a fourth all of data
science activities require computing
infrastructure and so how how should we
think about that I think about it in
terms of at least five tiers and these
are not meant to be mutually exclusive
so there's the connectivity and the
interface which sounds trivial but if
it's a desire to some origin requires
some thought and design you're going to
have to separate if you have a wet lab
but to separate that out from the dry
lab but that's necessarily separate so
you have to think about how you're going
to maintain connectivity from a data
point of view I hear and I think serving
the goal in the lab would be just to
provision those environments with high
bandwidth connections those wired in
Wi-Fi you have to think about how your
person your your personal or personnel I
should say here are are going to be
equipped with their personal machines so
it gets ounds trivial but it requires
someone to think about some kinds of
things which is your lab grows
can be a surprisingly large amount of
someone's time
now beyond someone's local desktop you
have two major resources in the data
science and laboratory to think about
you have the raw CPU power or compute
engines that we'd like to be able to
access and you're going to find are a
necessary part of working with big data
and of course storage of those data are
necessary is a necessary part of working
with big data here we use the private
servers and and the class the other
point to make about the compute engines
is we're seeing a trend just in the past
year or two Tauruses GPUs of graphics
processing units and ready-made cards by
video games I made originally for video
games and and high-performance graphics
for those kinds of applications by
companies like Nvidia there they're
essentially highly processed or a highly
parallel need to use that that one can
avail oneself this one has the right
libraries and it turns out that now in
video in particular support for
libraries for scientific computing on
GPUs it's really been revolutionary -
not just my lab but to a lot of of labs
I know in the data Sciences so if you're
just getting started really look
seriously at access to GPUs from your
own labs or not they're relatively
inexpensive now storage lies we do have
private storage and also cloud storage
and the private storage there's a
variety of reasons one one wishes to
have private storage not least of which
as we begin to get datasets for patients
one has to worry about a HIPAA
requirements dealing with patient
privacy and it's easier to worry about
those if one has a local storage unit
but of course we're also seeing HIPAA
compliance in the cloud so whether you
go to a local or cloud really starting
to become more personal decision that a
one which is easy to advise one way or
the other I would say you know the other
the other big consideration here is
latency one would like to have quick
access to the data which of course if
the connection is regulated to the
machine right next to you that latency
tend to be much less but that's also
changing there is what this all it looks
like which I think it always helps to
get some perspective I'm not going to
spend much time on this one other than
this day we hear a lot of the local
machines I talked about the compute and
the storage here at San Diego
supercomputing Center which is just a
half campus away so about a quarter mile
away from my lab with with that
connectivity through both experimental
and computational lab this is the
schematic of that base and so over here
you see businesses the compute part of
that cluster and here is the storage
part of that cluster and here is
representation at the local machine and
and of course the physical location
changes between the local machines and
lab and the SD SD machines control life
okay so the final thing I wanted to just
touch on is software development process
as we begin to think about our data data
Sciences project
it helps greatly and this I should say
took me ten years and a key conversation
with dr. terrorem unser at UBC who urge
me she runs a very successful lab at UBC
at data Sciences and a few years ago she
urged me to think about my my tool
development across four stages and and
whether whether she would have credited
to someone else maybe maybe she would
but I'm going to give her orc right here
so so first is to identify the most and
motivates the problem or the drawing
biological question along with the
target community that most and
benefit from answering that biological
question or challenge successfully
solving that problem
six-two is develop a prototype and not
worry about yet how you're going to to
convince the world that your prototype
is useful you already identify the need
now in stage 2 spend some time internal
to the lab and and get out that first
paper once that's out then you can focus
in stage 3 on making a robust software
tool or a website and database as the
case may be and that's not to put the
initial point of that first paper in
stage 2 that comes later and finally
once you have a mature resource that
begins to take a life of its own perhaps
even generate funding behind it then you
can worry about bra discrimination and
steps you can take to broadly encourage
the community and make sure your your
approach available and useful so the
first time you thought about this type
of for stage process was in planning our
national resource for get mythology for
doctor once there is an advisor she
convinced us to take all of our projects
to make this kind of chart and so on the
I'm not going to go into any detail here
but just to show you kind of the big
organizational view of all of this so in
rows of this chart you have a different
technology research development projects
for TR DS the different groups in this
consortium that are signed up for those
but then importantly across the columns
here you see those sports pages and so
now all of our research well first of
all planning phase one and then research
at stage two and three and development
in stages three and four it all now have
thought about in terms of a four stage
model in terms of for instance our
cytoscape software here's how I think
about the four stages so and this is
arguably for my lab the first software
tool that that came out of my mouth
in collaboration with several others
starting back in the year 2000 and so
the first was to identify the driving
problem in the target community which
here at the time it was clearer than
molecular biologists were generating
ever larger molecular networks we've
already talked all about the roots of
that 15 years later but at the time
there really were no tools to analyze
networks that large there were there
were certainly tools for dry and rap but
nothing of the magnitude that was needed
or the analytical complexity that was
needed and so that was the motivation we
first a code that ended up a permanent I
today first was used in a series of
prototypes studies which were biological
studies performed and published over a
few papers between the years 2000 and
2003 and the actual publication and
creation of high distinct itself as
initial releases in 2002 and its initial
marker paper with in 2003 but but it was
a real evolution of the code stating
always asked it even to late 90s through
2003 when we when we announced that tool
to the world now exist and of course we
continue to evolve the tool quite
dramatically every two to three years
and so every three or so years you want
to think about updating that effort with
with a publication but now it's lasting
here how do we get wrought adoption of
this cited paper resource and that
really is where I think luck played as
much of a role as a skill of planning
but there are definitely lessons to be
learned and the first big decision we
made here was to allow the cytoscape
core or to define and separate out a
part aside escape which is called the
core and a part which we called plugging
the time now they're called ax after
after the iPhone came along giving
people the ability to write their own
plugins or apps really change everything
for us and so if you want if you're
willing to put in the software
engineering effort then it can pay off
in terms of descent
and crowdsourcing because you're giving
them a mechanism by which to very
effectively crowdsource many of these
apps and there's over 200 of them that
are now developer site escape are also
themselves open source and so what that
means is we can actually absorb some of
that technology and use it to benefit
the core in future releases and
everyone's happy and and that's that's
really been a powerful model for us
other things we've done or maybe more
usual so we have an international
meeting around the increasing core
development community around plug-in
developer community in foresighted
states as well as having a biological
users of site of skateboard biases over
the past several years we've had a very
successful joining with the dream and
the reconcile Asia conference we decided
States in conjunction as a sort of three
for all and and NS integrates a great
development of course one also wants to
foster local community groups around
your tool and that's and and one can
identify individuals who are willing to
take lead roles in that and finally one
has to find these efforts as as they
progress and grow and here I think if
there's any one piece of advice I have
beyond the obvious if let go of
ownership realize that you're going to
be successful if your software is
successful and you want people to write
grants that are are essentially
extending your software or taking
ownership over your software unit and so
so becoming an open-source project
facilitating a developer community and
just letting go the reins as much as
possible you know of course what one
needs what one of course wants to
continue to contribute to the project
has been a really really key guideline
for us and so so you know not only now
do we have sighted itself but we have
this whole
satellites of tools that have been built
around height of space including the App
Store where you can download the app
some of these apps get downloaded
thousands of times inside as thousands
of times so they themselves in their own
right are are quite powerful sources and
I already talked about our inventions to
databases like like index so that
concludes my talk and I have tried to
touch really on four different points
which were key in building my my own
data Sciences laboratory and and and I
think they're clearly going to be key
considerations for anyone getting
getting started or or building into the
future and so with that I will thank you
for your time especially given that I
think I just competed with Donald Trump
inaugural address if you were still in
this call I think you made the right
decision so to say but we've got I will
I will take any questions thank you for
this wonderful talk so we actually have
time for one quick question so the first
question that's well actually got a lot
of questions for this but I'm just going
to choose one so what are your thoughts
on using of makerspaces for data price
levels do you have any thoughts on that
are there any data size makers out there
could use a space like this that is that
is a wonderful suggestion
I had several lab members who are big
participation in maker movement um I
result could not have not tried going
down that road um my guess is the
depending on what environments you you
are in if you're in a university
environment that has a biological
science department my guess is it might
actually be easier just to go your
neighbor and use their major space
that's provided by the University but I
would love to hear people talk
experiences with that okay well we're
out of time um thank you so much and
we'll conclude
top today thank you